we opted for a distributed structure
which was in essence a precursor of
cloud computing that we all know today
and we called it the grid we've agreed
you are able to share resources
computing resources storage resources so
you are able to share a lot of computers
connected to together and be able to use
them as a single big computational
resource the tr0 computer center
operates as just one part of the Large
Hadron Collider computing grid which is
a worldwide organization federation of
data centers that process the data that
is produced by detectors around the
Large Hadron Collider there are I run
one 150 computing centers dr0 is a
computing center at CERN in Tier one we
have 11 big computing centers that are
available there for us every day of the
year anytime for the for experiments
only last year there were like 30
petabytes of data this data all ends up
in the 2-0 data center then it is
massaged a little bit processed and then
it's sent off to Tier one data centers
for further processing the different
delicacy detectors are connected to the
Sun computing center with a dedicated
network of 10 gigabytes per second
network sites are very powerful network
and they store this data permanently in
tape storage then cell is connected also
through dedicated links of 10 gigabits
per second as well to 11 computing
centers all around the world this data
is transferred depends on the
experiments it was to one or another and
then we have hundreds of other computing
centers that are part of this w LCD this
LHC computing grid where we are also
processing and storing the data so you
see the data is doing a very big journey
all around the globe if i'm professor
john doe working out of the university
in italy i would want to know what
happened in a specific detector or in a
specific sub detector of a detector i
might request this file that would then
reflect a recording of what happened at
that time and this file might be stored
in my data center I might have a cached
copy of it it might be stored
a data center that's completely in a
different part of the world you know it
could be in a server somewhere in the US
or it could be retrieved from the to
zero data center here at CERN this file
band would come back to me through a
unified file system that spans all the
organizations that work with CERN that
are on the grid and I would see it as if
it were in my local file system and if
that file for example is not at this but
on tape obviously I would have to wait
longer because there's probably a queue
to the tape robot and then the tape
robot has to go get my tape has to read
it then serve the file to me and so on
and so on
so if I'm lucky I'm going to get it in a
fraction of a second if I'm unlucky I
might get it in an hour or maybe in
several hours but this is relatively
infrequent these days one thing is the
storage of the data and another thing is
the computing of that data first you
have to make sure the data is stored
somewhere in a permanent way so we can
retrieve this whenever we need to and
then you need the computing power to be
able to run all these programs the
physicists write to be able to find the
Higgs boson or we produce the conditions
after a collision and see what has
happened which particles have been
created you need a lot of computing for
this so you need both both sides you
need a storage and you need the
computing power people initially thought
why don't we build a big data center
just right at CERN but that was not
really a good solution because first of
all we wouldn't have too much to do with
it when we don't really do anything else
so there were the only one specific
purpose for it and then all the other
scientist would like to participate in
this effort would not have the
opportunity to do so if they all want to
use this powerful grid you've created
how do you prioritize how is it decided
who gets to use the power and when there
is a very important component in the
grid which is what we call the
middleware let me nervous is the
software that is actually making look
all these scattered resources as a huge
computer computational resource so
thanks to the middleware we have a way
to prioritize was a way to make sure
only the right users had using the
resources or security source an
important aspect making sure the right
people are using the right resources we
allocate computing power or storage per
experiment so the middleware is actually
managing all this and making sure the
priorities are
everybody's able to do their job the
grid is called a grid because there is
an analogy with electricity grid so
electricity is something that you don't
actually care what it comes from in fact
it is coming from different providers it
could be with the wind it could be cold
that brings together electricity
you just plug in your toaster or your
radio and it works so the idea of the
computing grid would be this and we are
still far from from this use that we
have with the electricity grid now we
are not able to say I connect my
whatever a computer and then I know I
would have a limited access to computing
resources that who know where they are
this is not possible yet but that will
decide the idea behind the degree that
we would be able to use it in the same
way we use electricity it's not hardware
that you can buy in your typical
computer shop but it's not very far from
that you know essentially what we run to
the computing Center RPC servers
sometimes with some improvements or some
experimental hardware but the majority
of production is something that you can
buy off a list from a vendor today now
that is what we have in the data center
but if you go closer to the experiments
and you want to look at the systems that
collect the data they become more and
more custom the grid was designed before
we knew that the web would be a big
thing it's just another protocol to
access files so the world wide web is
again just another protocol to access
files and remote servers and in this
case we need slightly different
characteristics than you have with a
standard web processing you know we
would like to process bigger files we
would like to transfer them faster or we
would like to synchronize files across
multiple locations in the world you know
the world wide web can't do that but the
protocols that sit on top of these files
that interface between us and those
files really can make that happen
we have increased our capacity to to
execute all these jobs benefiting from
the fact that we can only count on all
these computers Large Hadron Collider
computing grid today has probably
350,000 computing cores and you know if
you if we look at that figure one hour
later it's probably going to be more
than that
so it keeps changing over time we start
at the beginning that the LXE was going
to produce something like 15 petabytes
of data and when we turn on the LHC and
we run it - we went far beyond our
expectation so we've generated much more
data than what we thought at the
beginning I think it's amazing that
these 350,000 processors can work
together they can produce results that
feed the scientists you know across the
whole world and that out of these
results you can then produce a plot
which changes the way we understand
physics so the physicists definitely can
consume any amount of computing you're
going to show them so if you telling me
have 10 new computers they would
immediately like to use them and they
will surely find new types of analysis
to run on those computers and they will
put into good use but on the other hand
you've asked about a very interesting
topic which is that of new technologies
and that of whether we need to adapt our
software and our way of thinking about
computers to be able to profit fully
from those technologies and if you take
you know the topic of accelerators for
example which is you know either GPUs or
devices like the Knights family like the
Knights corner from from Intel which
they also called the Xeon Phi you can't
really take the software that you have
today and just put it on that device
like that and expect that your your
computation is going to be accelerated
you have to put some more effort into
that processor performance still keeps
improving along with Moore's Law but now
more than ever we need to put more
thinking into what changes in computing
mean for us what do we have to do to
adapt to those changes how do we take
advantage of next-generation technology
like for example you know there might be
new processors coming up they have new
features such as you know white vectors
you might have to do vectorization you
might have to do multi or many core
processing and some of the software that
you've designed 20 years ago might not
be ready for this because nobody has
expected that things would develop this
way so I think there's you know despite
the fact that we're very efficiently
using the computers we have at our
disposal today there are still managed
there are still many challenges ahead of
us to make sure that we can profit from
the most recent technologies
you
the LHC has evolved
computing project which is called LHC at
home where you would be helping
physicists to carry out simulations that
are very important for them to
afterwards compare them with the real
data and this won't increase the grid we
use for the real data but it's going to
be a very important part in the
processing of some of the work that the
physicists need to do anyway